which is why i'd like to give
richard wolff a shout out for being an
intellectual who talks about communism
i think it's it takes kind of a heroic
intellectual right now
to speak about like communism seriously
there's difficult waters to tread set
the expression
there's difficult paths to walk i love
watching a robot try to use idiom in a
language
zero zero one one
i'm i'm not quite deeply hurt by the
binary comment
are you your feeling has gone from one
to zero
yeah what is my buffers have overflown
uh though but there's difficult i i feel
like communism
is uh like universally seen as a bad
thing currently in intellectual circles
yes or
actually maybe some people disagree with
that people say like far
far left people are trying to you know
there's some people who argue the
the blm movement is some kind of
marxist i mean i don't i don't really
follow the deep logic
in that whatever but uh you know it's
just well they said they're informed by
marxism the founder co-founder
yeah but stating that is different
than um there's there's mark's the the
totalitarian there's also marks the
revolutionary and i think they're
talking more like
we're revolutionaries we're going to
overthrow the status quo yeah right but
like
we can have that further discussion but
i i just don't think they speak
deeply about uh political systems of and
saying communism
is uh is going to be the righteous
system that
you know there's not a deep intellectual
discourse what i mean but if you were to
try to be on stage with the jordan
peterson
like to me the brave thing now like
it would be to argue for communism it'd
be interesting to see
not many people do it uh i certainly
wouldn't be willing to do it i don't
have enough
i don't first of all don't believe it
but second of all it's a very difficult
argument to make because you'll get so
much fire
which is why i like richard wolff he's
one of the people who is
quite rigorously showing that there's
some good ideas within the system of
communism
uh specifically saying that uh attacking
more the
the negative sides of capitalism so
saying that there is
uh that capitalism potentially is more
dangerous than communism
i mean it's i i disagree with that but i
think it's a
i love how something is like we've got a
body count of 60 million
but this everything is potent
potentially you know like water
can drown everyone on earth so this is
incoherent
well i i think nuclear weapons are bad
but nuclear energy is good
sure that's so nuclear weapons are also
can be good you can easily make the
argument which i don't know that i
subscribe to
that nuclear weapons prevented uh
boot something around war and or it
caused them to be much more contained
and they're also quite effective at
changing the direction of an asteroid
that's about to hit earth
as i've learned from uh yeah again
and they're actually useful as elon musk
has claimed for uh
uh for application for prior to
colonizing mars
making it uh more habitable oh okay so
it changed
something uh
but yes but i guess what i'm saying is
there's there's place for nuance
and there's some topics so hot like
communism where nuance
is very difficult to to have and that i
feel like
with nazi germany it was a similar thing
at the time
you